avete appena sentito luca che diceva
birra vi diremo quale opportunità dalla
sardegna alla crisi di questo volevo
parlarvi di questo termine della crisi
perché in quest'ultimo periodo è
soprattutto in questi ultimi giorni
avrete avuto modo di sentire il termine
crisi come se fosse qualcosa di positivo
la crisi deriva dal greco vuol dire
scegliere vuol dire criticare vuol dire
individuare un periodo di transizione
c'è un ideogramma cinese che ci dice che
crisi si scrive come opportunità sembra
quasi che la crisi sia qualcosa di
positivo
io chiederò poi alla micro se c'è un
ideogramma cinese che vuol dire vai al
diavolo
e se a qualche altro significato poi
cerchiamo di capire perché la crisi
signori è una cosa bruttissima la crisi
a volte non trova mai il fondo è meglio
non essere mai in crisi
per quanto possa dare opportunità per
quanto posso dare opportunità la crisi è
meglio evitarli non ho mai sentito
nessuno chiamato finalmente sono in
crisi possono avere il modo di rialzarmi
non è così la crisi peraltro si
caratterizza non dal termine in sé ma
dall'aggettivo che gli mettiamo a fianco
perché ci può essere la crisi
matrimoniale e sono affari dei coniugi
ma quello che caratterizza questa crisi
è la crisi economica c'è un tesoro
questo tesoro si erode e fino a quando è
solo un problema di natura economica la
crisi rimane abbastanza circoscritta il
problema è che quando ti vengono meno le
possibilità economica quando lo ti
vengono meno le opportunità a questo
punto c'è qualcosa in più che si innesca
si innesca una mancanza di funzionamento
del dl pulsantino si innesca un altro
problema meno opportunità vuol dire
anche erosione di capitale sociale
quando c'è la crisi
quando si hanno meno soldi quella rete
inter fiduciaria che abbatte anche i
costi di intermediazione quindi fa
risparmiare su alcune cose non mi compro
il trattore perché tu me lo presti se tu
non mi presti più il trattore
io me lo devo comprare se lo ricche solo
un po più povero se mi compro il
trattore
spendo ulteriori soldi vuol dire che le
persone non si passano più la coppa e
vuol dire che le persone non sostengono
più le persone qualcuno di questi sì tra
indietro e quindi ci vuole qualcosa di
più e se si comincia a erodere il
capitale sociale
capita un'altra cosa brutta
sì e no nel capitale culturale non si
spendono più soldi per la cultura
qualche imbecille dice anche che con la
cultura non si mangia
e magari anche qualcuno che può gestire
il potere da quel punto di vista e
succede una cosa bruttissima non abbiamo
più i meccanismi per ricostruire il
capitale sociale
e veniamo a perdere anche i meccanismi
che ci permettono di accumulare capitale
economico e succede un'altra cosa ancora
più brutta quando siamo in crisi e la
crisi persiste che siano del capitale
istituzionale ci sono istituzioni meno
qualificate ci sono più opportunismi
quando si va a gestire le istituzioni le
nazioni falliscono per questo perché non
c'è k tiziana istituzionale quindi
abbiamo un processo di degrado un
processo degenerativo se vogliamo
utilizzare un termine biologico perché
poi la società è un soggetto biologico
dove vi è meno la ricchezza di e meno il
capitale sociale vie meno il capitale
culturale vengono meno le istituzioni e
la fiducia nelle istituzioni
abbiamo questa situazione di degrado di
degenerazione
passiamo dalla crisi economica ha una
situazione che si chiama di declino
situazione economica e carenza di
ricchezza crisi economica declino
cominciamo erode nel capitale sociale
culturale e dopo il declino c'è un unico
elemento la decadenza poi immaginate voi
dove siamo noi adesso ognuno ha la sua
idea di come si sta spostando la società
italiana e sarda in particolare e quando
arriviamo nel periodo di decadenza
con tutto rispetto per i barbari
arrivano i barbari legano i capi attorno
alla statua di augusto che qui è un
sacerdote
e quello della pace equa augusto non è
il conquistatore e quello delle strade
che augusto arrivano i barbari e mettono
il cappio intorno ad agosto cambia il
paradigma non ho più il dialogo non è
più questo è la violenza che viene in
gioco nelle regole di confronto tra i
soggetti e quando c'è la violenza
l'ultimo dei centurioni romani armato di
una daga come ben sapete è più
importante di archimede vuol dire che
cambia completamente il paradigma della
vita
cosa possiamo fare questa è la domanda
che poi mi si apposta ma secondo te che
fai il direttore del centro regionale di
programmazione eccetera eccetera quale
può essere l'elemento che può
intervenire sia che siamo in fase di
crisi si sa che siamo in fase di declino
ossia che sia minac la rata decadenza
come può il territorio ri diventare
competitivo perché poi nella situazione
di crisi non è che tutti soffrono la
crisi nella maniera uguale aumentano
anche i divari tra i territori questa
che vi faccio vedere adesso si chiama
blub ad amazon una banana blu cosa
misura misurava fino al 2010 le 100
regioni più competitive d'europa basate
sull'indice regionale di competitività
misurato dall'ocse e dalla commissione
europea
partiva dall ombra prendeva parigi il
benelux la baviera e arrivava fino alla
lombardia
beh signori nella rilevazione 2014 la
banana non è più in italia
il pezzo superiore della banana non
esiste più
le regioni e anche la lombardia non è
più tra le 100 regioni più competitive
dell'europa però l'idea è ok se siamo in
grado di misurare la competitività
se andiamo a verificarsi gli indicatori
che determinano la competitività di una
regione
andiamo a vederle magari scopriamo
qualcosa di interessante
scopriamo per esempio che tra il gruppo
degli indicatori di base infrastrutture
sostanzialmente tra il gruppo di
indicatori di efficienza e quelli di
innovazione
c'è una linea comune che possiamo
prendere
ed è esattamente il capitale umano ed è
esattamente lo sviluppo umano
se andiamo a vederli vediamo che c'è
l'educazione di base c'è la ilte
educazione c'è l'innovazione e quindi se
io volessi con un piccolo sforzo
investire su qualcosa che mi consente
nello stesso momento di attivare i tre
blocchi di competitività delle regioni
la prima cosa che devo fare è mettere in
evidenza il capitale umano la capacità
che le persone hanno di svilupparsi se
dovessi aspettare di rimettere in moto
le condizioni di base con le strade con
le cose per poter andare a individuare
l'italia attivare gli occhi e gli
indicatori di efficienza c passerebbero
decenni noi non ce l'abbiamo questo
tempo non ce l'abbiamo
abbiamo la necessità di un idea
improvvisa esclusiva alternativa alla
vincita al superenalotto chiaramente che
possa innescare delle politiche
pubbliche virtuose
dobbiamo prenderci prenderci quella
freccia che prima bucava il pavimento e
con uno sforzo girarla verso girare alla
verso l'altro quello sono io a proposito
quindi vuol dire dove la nostra miniera
d'oro
dobbiamo andare a capire qual è la
nostra miniera d'oro a cielo aperto
questa magari una cosa non è quella di
furtei comunque questo
ora mi sono rivolto al nostro emisfero
destro
adesso mi rivolgo al vostro capacità
analitiche quindi darò solo numeri
questo d'ora in poi solo numeri
il primo numero qui non c'è il primo
numero e 24,7 per cento che il tasso di
dispersione scolastico della sardegna il
più alto d'europa
io ritengo che la nostra miniera d'oro
sia lì in quel quarto di nostri
concittadini che non raggiungono neanche
il diploma di quel quarto dei nostri
cittadini che sono la nostra vera
miniera d'oro perché perché il 40 per
cento dei laureati il i laureati hanno
la possibilità di trovare lavoro
rispetto a diplomati per un 40 per cento
in più
sondati del mezzogiorno nel mezzogiorno
e dati attuali in questo momento di
crisi il 53 per cento dei laureati trova
lavoro entro il primo anno dalla laurea
nello sfigato mezzogiorno il 53 per
cento di giu il primo anno trova lavoro
dopo un paio d'anni arriva al 74 per
cento
qui da noi non in lombardia che i dati
sono molto molto molto più alti una
laurea magistrale nel mezzogiorno costa
31.750 euro prendi tuo figlio lo fai
laureare ti costa 21.750 euro
il primo stipendio di un laureato a
16.800 euro 1.400 euro per 12 mensilità
circa il 53 per cento di quello che hai
investito per fare laureare quei ragazzi
cominciate a fissare questi numeri
perché poi faremo un ragionamento
altro elemento curioso interessante ma
quanto ci costa far crescere un ragazzo
da 0 a 18 anni ci costa esattamente 170
mila euro
io due gemelle fate il calcolo quasi 18
anni quanto speso però 170 mila euro
da 0 a 18 anni compresa la paghetta la
ricarica telefonica qualsiasi spesa
valutaria necessaria che volete metterci
in media costa 170 mila euro di questi
170 mila euro il 12 per cento va
nell'educazione dalla scuola
dell'infanzia alle scuole elementari
alle scuole medie alle scuole superiori
tutto compreso comprendo il bavaglino
dalle scuole delle scuole delle scuole
della scuola d'infanzia 170 mila euro
se io faccio un piccolo calcolo semplice
calcolo il 12 per cento di 170mila ci
aggiungo 3.750 euro ottengono a ci sta
che di 52 mila e 150 euro
io in tre anni virgola uno di lavoro
ammesso e non concesso che mi rimanga
quello stipendio riesco a ripagarmi
tutte le spese dell'educazione partendo
dai 0 anni in tre anni virgola uno se
avessi studiato alla bocconi non avrei
speso 31.750 avrei speso 85 mila euro
per arrivare alla alla laurea magistrale
però al primo anno avrei guadagnato
44.680 euro
ugualmente il rapporto è sempre
superiore al 53 per cento rispetto al
totale della spesa della laurea e in
ogni caso qualsiasi università prendo
qualsiasi ragione prendo il rendimento è
sempre superiore al 30 per cento
dell'investimento iniziale che ho fatto
e non vale solo per la laurea vale
soprattutto per la scuola d'infanzia voi
sapete che in italia in una cittadina
dell'emilia ci sono le migliori scuole
d'infanzia del mondo e sono
studiatissime da poco james heckman
premio nobel per l'economia nel 2000 ha
cominciato lo studio sull'approccio
emiliano alla scuola d'infanzia per
dimostra per applicare la sua equazione
e per dimostrare che ogni euro investito
nella scuola dell'infanzia 0 5 anni
genera reddito che può essere calcolato
studi iniziato nel 2011 che sta
continuando e che vede il comune di
reggio emilia con l'università di
chicago dove insegna dove insegna
jackman è l'equazione diekmann è molto
semplice è questa se investi e favorisce
l'ingresso nell'educazione anche delle
famiglie disagiate
se sviluppi le capacità intellettive dei
bambini da 0 a 5 anni
se questi poi li sostiene fino a quando
diventano adulti acquisiscano gli
ulteriori competenze ci guadagni ma non
guadagni capitale sociale solamente ci
guadagni in denaro e ci guadagni in
denaro
il soggetto ci guadagna in denaro nella
famiglia ci guadagna in denaro
immediatamente la società e ci
guadagnano in denaro soprattutto le
generazioni future
cosa vuol dire questo vuol dire che se
io avessi un euro lo sto cercando
scusate oppure se avessi
un dollaro no incidentalmente vi invito
anche a notare cos'è la politica
e cos'è la burocrazia come si vendono le
unità di misura
se avessi queste dove investirei secondo
voi 0 45 e il rendimento lordo dei bot
quinquennali dell'asta di agosto
mettetelo 0 45 dell'investimento
nell'educazione
mettete il 53 per cento degli investit
sera 45 nell'investimento nei bot e il
53 per cento invece degli investimenti
in educazione e fatemi calcoli grazie